I feel quite I didn't I think mother is
not quite it's quite amazing to see you
all and I do feel well actually I feel
very proud and I am looking around the
room I actually think mathematics
education is improvable hands just
quietly all these are wonderful young
people going out and and welcome back to
those of you who of course are already
teachers I'm so pleased you can you're
on your holidays you've given up your
holiday to come in and to spend some
time talking about mathematics education
meeting their current students I'm just
so delighted you do that and I have had
quite a few emails from people who have
said they'd love to be here but they
can't they're booked tomorrow days
overseas etc so thank you so much first
of all I'd also like to introduce a
couple of other guests that Robyn has
mentioned associate professor
palladian from the science faculty we
also have professor never weather is
here Nevel who's the head of the school
of math and statistics from the science
faculty associate professor David ease
down may not be here at the moment I he
is up with that David director of
first-year mathematics in the Faculty of
science welcome and thanks for coming
over David Price is over here David is
one of the tutors in first-year
mathematics at the moment and is also an
X secondary teacher and is bringing
wonderful support for our first year
students as well professor John back
will be joining us later in the day two
for the song I John Buck wouldn't see
you up there John welcome John Mack is
some a very famous mathematician from
this university who was also head of
academic board and he's going to present
summer fun his research after lunch in
the issue session so welcome to all of
you also Stewart perman who's down the
front Stewart some of you with know
Stuart's been working here with me for
the last three or four years i think in
the pre-service programs so welcome
Stewart and thanks for your contribution
and we have world Robin welcome to
Marilyn but um I just would like to say
who better
it ought to give the opening keynote
than the lead author of our textbook you
all brought your pot to have an
autograph okay now let's just turn to
our alumni for a moment if I may a
little indulgence some of you have
actually traveled quite a long way to be
he who are the teachers in the audience
from country New South Wales I'm not
where we're from from maxvill from
kangaroo valley from high school wow so
these people know you've given up the
holidays but they've also traveled
actually a fair way to be with us thank
you so much for joining us really
appreciate it I'm just to give you an
idea of the years that people graduated
or when they were here who have we got
in the audience who is he when I first
came in 2003 who was a student with me
in 2003
to the golden oldies and of course 2004
who work weekly in 2004 we've got a few
summer some of the same mr. Haven fuel
2005 come up the back and five two
thousand six with me 2006 a few 2007
that was a Gucci representatives from
2007 well done guys are 2008 quite a few
2009 not so much recently 2010 2011 and
now we started to get to people who are
actually still here aren't we 12 and 13
it's it just so i actually young with
back through my archives actually like
18 I didn't have many photographs
unfortunately I have to right that wrong
this is the same group I hate looking at
these photos realize how much of age in
my mind my own age and of course some of
you I actually do catch up with
regularly it makes for conferences so
some of you I have seen quite a few
over these others of you I haven't seen
since you've left but I do enjoy seeing
people at the conferences but I'm good
you're also today going to meet the new
crop of teachers so those of you who
have traveled to a teacher's I'm hoping
today you're going to be had me really
impressed with the current crop of
teachers that we actually have here and
quite a few of you in the audience I'm
actually looking forward to your
reactions as some of them actually
present in the intercession so why not
unlike conference who came up with the
idea it's something that I had thought
about over the years but norden who's
down the front said to me when we
graduated you must have an alumni
conference and he's mentioned it several
times since and finally I've got my act
together with support from other people
and we're actually this is the first one
and wouldn't it be wonderful if this
became an annual event and I know there
are lots of other teachers out there who
have liked you've been here what is
really important today in your bag
you've got a great sheet of paper
there's an evaluation and I'm really
keen on your feedback whether you're a
pre-service teacher or a parent teacher
I want some honest feedback on today
because I would like to do this again
but I'd like you to tell me what works
to you what didn't four starts we're
overcrowded now that's a good thing that
I've got so many people here and I did
try with moving this to another venue
but actually wanted to keep it in
faculty for this first one but we are
overflowing so changing the venue and
going to either the law school or one of
the other larger lecture fears is
obviously something that I would have to
consider because everyone is obviously
make sure the guests have internet
access it is clear we can all write down
and I'm sure there's others that you'll
think about on during the day please
give feedback those of you who are
looking for teacher accreditation I need
those evaluation pardon me those
evaluation sheets at the end of the day
as evidence that you've been here for
the whole day and then we can get you
accreditation with the new south wales
institute of teachers I'd like everybody
to handing the evaluation shoot those
you leave okay to the program you've got
a copy of the program in your bag you
can see that it's very packed in very
full so we've actually gotten a lot to
do ah I think we'll get through it it
might be a bit of a rush but again that
might be something we read things to
missed you what I'd like to do now is
hand over to Leon to just tell you a
little bit about the project that
actually helped to fund your food today
so we finish to keep this at no cost for
you to attend now normally conferences
cost a lot of money for hiring auras of
our facilities for food etc today we're
not charging you anything so it's pretty
good free pdf I think but Leon would
like to show you
about the project was painful well i'm
sure kevin rudd and chili gil either i'm
glad that they're 12 12 million dollars
is being spent on your food today so
into it during the years of the
rudd-gillard rudd government they
decided that there should be more
investment in the the training and the
ongoing professional development of
mathematics and science teachers so
there was this inspiring mathematics and
science teacher education project of
ours which was one of the successful
projects there are six around the
country in enhancing the training of
mathematics and science teachers program
and marilyn is the leader of our project
and i'm not going to say very much but
just let you know that it's actually a
collaboration between six different
universities that are quite different in
size and in a type of teacher education
they do so I've been Queensland we've
got James Cook to the University of
Queensland New South Wales we have new
castle rock and here at Sydney and we
also have the University of Tasmania
involved as well so at each one of those
universities there are projects going on
we all get together and meet on a
regular basis and there'll be another
event involving this project sometime in
June and there are basically three
important strategies that we're looking
at two of those strategies are key today
to the first year so recruitment and
retention we want to build a sense of
community amongst the people in this
room so please use this opportunity to
meet people who are here today that you
wouldn't otherwise meet and try and we
will try to help you build ongoing
relationships and connections using
technology and various other events
combined with face-to-face so it brought
back our alumni and we're indulging in
some professional development for them
as well and allowing them to renew find
out what's going on in the university
find out what
issues are of the latest researchers and
so on and of course we're also going to
be looking at the design of our crossing
some universities and as you can notice
those of you who studied here years ago
would know that there was very little
interaction between the Faculty of
science of the Faculty of Education is
almost like there wasn't a single person
that was talking between them that's all
going to change so the little gems of
interaction we hope will become the law
and that there will be a regular ongoing
and healthy dialogue between all the
different parts at the University of the
relevant to your current studies to your
training and to your lifelong
professional development so as I said
I'm not going to sleep very long because
it's a huge pronoun to get through but
that's where the money's coming from
that's funding this activity they're the
people involved and you'll find out a
lot more about this project over the
rest of today and over the next few
years as well so when your self head
back to duty